well hello there people of the internet
I am really confused and conflicted
frankly about the Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom here we have the sequel
to what is the best-selling Zelda game
of all time releasing on one of the
best-selling consoles of all time oh and
it just so happened it's one of the
highest Metacritic reviewed games of all
time as well so what's the problem tears
at the Kingdom set up to be a Surefire
hit right what is there to be confused
about we finally saw some extensive
gameplay in a recent Nintendo Direct and
the reaction has been interesting to say
the least now personally for me I've
played quite a few of the Zelda games
over the years I've enjoyed the vast
majority in fact I don't think there's
any Zelda game that I just flat out did
not like even Skyward Sword which is my
least favorite Zelda game overall I
still found it enjoyable even if I have
quite a few critiques for that game
after Skyward sword's release in 2011
most agreed the series needed a bit of a
reimagining many fans argued in favor of
a more open world with the freedom to
explore and breath of the wild delivered
on all of this in a big way so I played
it day one launch day same day that the
Nintendo switch released and by and
large I enjoyed it even if I don't rank
it among like the best games ever made
like a lot of people do I still had a
great time with the game I mean it is a
top tier experience one of my most
memorable gaming experiences for sure
but still I wouldn't put it in that kind
of upper echelon of greatest games of
all time like I've seen from a lot of
people so lately I've been playing more
recent titles Jedi Fallen order a little
bit older but I'm playing that in
preparation for Jedi Survivor God of War
Ragnarok Hogwarts Legacy and so to be
totally honest with you guys when I
first saw the gameplay I mean just my
initial reaction of Tears of the kingdom
was oh my goodness this looks so
incredibly dated I mean going from those
more modern titles to this was just
jarring and I want to be clear before
you guys start yelling at me Graphics
are not everything there are some
fantastic games out there that don't
look all that good graphically but tears
just look so dated to me guys so dated
and trust me I know it's running on
dated Hardware I mean some would even
say the Nintendo switch was dated when
it released we keep waiting when is the
switch to when is the switch Pro going
to come out we thought Nintendo was
going to do that thing they normally do
or at least I should say that thing
they've been doing lately with Zelda
games where they release it on an older
system and then also release it on a
newer system I mean we saw that with
Twilight Princess releasing on the
GameCube and on the Wii then we saw it
again with breath of the wild which I
did not even remember did you guys know
that game released on the Wii U yeah
released on the Wii U and of course the
Nintendo switch now as I mentioned I
played breath of the wild day one and I
do not remember it looking this bad so I
had to test this out right away I pulled
out my Nintendo switch OLED popped in
the cartridge and was pleasantly
surprised I didn't think at least on the
handheld side it did not look nearly as
bad as what we just saw with tears of
the Kingdom I did go ahead and dock it
then pulled it up on my monitor and
while it definitely looked worse on the
larger screen losing some of the
sharpness that you get when you're
playing on handheld mode I still thought
it looked better than what Nintendo just
showed us I mean you be the judge take a
look at this side by side footage here
breath of the Wild on the left that is
running on my Nintendo switch I think it
looks much better visually and I've also
watched quite a few other videos
breaking this down some seem to believe
that this could be like maybe a YouTube
compression issue with Nintendo's upload
I just can't imagine that a title being
developed from the ground up for the
switch all these years later would
somehow look worse now I don't expect it
to look just way better don't expect
that at all but how could they go
backwards surely not right surely not
but that aside let's just assume that
the final version of the game at least
looks on par with breath of the wild do
we then have valid concerns when it
comes to the graphics
and this is where it really starts to
get tricky right I mean for me
personally I am not a graphics above all
else kind of guy I know if you are a PS5
or Xbox series X player or PC player and
then you're going back to play your
Nintendo switch as well it can be like I
said in the beginning it can be a
jarring experience and I think the
biggest reason for that is because in
the back of my mind it's like I'm always
thinking how good this could look how
smooth this could be running right now
and trust me I know I know I promise I
know it's not Nintendo's thing right
they're not gonna be on The Cutting Edge
of Hardware they bowed out of that a
long time ago I mean really with the Wii
that's when they said look we're not
going to compete on the graphics front
anymore we're going to do something
unique something different and they have
mastered that two out of the three times
we did a pretty good job Wii U and not
so much the switch of course has been a
smashing success so I get all of those
things when people say you can't expect
this from Nintendo but you guys the
switch Hardware it is so outdated at
this point I mean if we have ad The
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
running on a current gen system and
compared it to the switch it would
almost be like a two generation leap
think about that this is the Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild running on a
high-end PC of course through an
emulator in 4k at an incredibly silky
smooth frame rate now I don't know
there's some more Shader things or
something that they've been upgrading
for this one but you have to agree right
this is absolutely gorgeous I mean I'm
mesmerized when I found this footage
online the world that's there underneath
what you see on your Nintendo switch it
is absolutely
breathtakingly beautiful it's just being
held back by the hardware okay so
setting all of that aside I do believe
Graphics aside Nintendo can still
deliver a quality enjoyable experience
with an open world game in 2023 on dated
hardware and make it fun but here's the
key so long as that performance doesn't
start to actually bleed into the
gameplay and here we're talking about
things like frame rate if the game
really struggles if it really chugs and
we saw this a little bit with breath of
the wild to be honest do you notice lots
of texture pop into the physics work
always how they're supposed to work and
to be fair the physics that was
definitely one of the strong suits of
breath of the wild this Graphics thing
is one that is so subjective and really
depends on you and your personal taste
as a gamer I know for me personally I do
believe I'll be able to get past it it
may be hard at the beginning coming from
all these next-gen games and then going
back and be like oh man this is so
jarring because I'll have that nagging
thought this footage that we just looked
at of breath of the wild running in 4k
I'll have that in the back of my mind
knowing how good it could look but when
Nintendo gameplay is King and breath of
the wild had some really fun gameplay
sections and I think over time as I
really start to get into the game I'm
hoping that some of that will fade away
I don't know maybe I should play it all
on handheld mode I think it'll look even
better in handheld than it does on the
big screen and that really leads me to
the second big thing I keep seeing
online in terms of people critiquing
what we've seen so far and it's the
question of is this enough with tears of
the Kingdom to Warrant a full-fledged
sequel or is it just a glorified DLC I
think what has people concerned is the
fact that it takes place in the very
same Hyrule from breath of the wild now
there are already quite a few of these
videos out there where you can go and
see these side by side comparisons so
you can see just how close they are and
to be fair there are some differences as
well that you can see but by and large
it is the same Hyrule the biggest
addition seems to be these Sky Islands
which admittedly they do look massive
and like there's going to be a great
deal new to discover with these now in
that recent Nintendo Direct Nintendo
really made sure they focused on these
new gameplay mechanics there's the
recall ability which allows you to
reverse time on an object so you can
hitch a ride on the these giant blocks
that fall from the sky by recalling them
there's also the fusibility which lets
you take weapons and combine them with
objects in the world to make the weapon
more powerful so it does more damage and
also more durable so it doesn't break as
easily and yep that's right it seems
like weapons breaking down is still
going to be a thing in tears of the
Kingdom Ultra hand is another ability
this one will essentially let you glue
objects together and they showed link
building a little makeshift raft here
using three logs and then fusing on
these powered fans to get it across the
lake one of the strengths of breath of
the wild was how the game really gave
you the freedom and encourage you to
just try things the physics were amazing
and a lot of times there were multiple
ways to approach a puzzle or combat
scenario thanks to all of Link's
abilities I mean even now this year
there are new Secrets being discovered
new gameplay mechanics that people are
figuring out with breath of the wild
just because of how open it was and how
you could approach these scenarios in so
many different ways and with all of
these new features Nintendo showed off
it seems like they are doubling down on
this vast open world and giving the
player all of these tools to play with
to see what you can come up with they're
really encouraging the player to think
creatively in this open world if it's
anything like the first game in that
regard they're not going to be holding
your hand either they're not going to
show you every single little detail
every single feature of these abilities
they want you to explore and experiment
the last one they showed off was another
traversal mechanic this one called
Ascend if you have a scenario where you
don't want to climb all the way to the
top of a structure but you can get
inside at a lower level you can use this
Ascend ability to essentially pass
through the structure all the way to the
top I personally thought all of the
abilities look fun and interesting and
they're definitely going to change up
the gameplay Loop to a pretty
significant degree I think especially in
the case of fuse and Ultra hand I think
they're going to be so many different
strategies and New Creations that people
come up with using those two abilities
but that's not even beginning to mention
the abilities we don't know about yet
there's going to be so much in this game
Nintendo is always very very careful
about what they show they never want to
show too much so I think they were
trying to show us just a little taste of
the new gameplay elements and those two
alone is going to open up so many new
gameplay possibilities all in all it
certainly seems like Nintendo is going
all in on the formula that they
established with breath of the wild
while I personally enjoyed that formula
I know there's quite a few old school
fans out there who were hoping they
would be able to bring in maybe a few
more of the classic Zelda gameplay
elements like Dungeons now to be fair we
don't know for sure if dungeons are not
in the game there's no confirmation one
way or another and personally I mean I'm
one of those people I would love to see
dungeons come back and they absolutely
did need to freshen things up after
Skyward Sword I think they totally made
the right call to do something different
but there were still just a few things
that it was lacking and for me I really
did miss the traditional dungeons now to
those of you out there like me who may
be still hoping for that I think we have
to realize though that the proof is in
the pudding so to speak this game breath
of the wild is by far by far the
best-selling Zelda title ever I mean if
you go and look at like the second third
and fourth I think if you add up the
second third and fourth best-selling
Zelda titles of all time they still do
not outsell breath of the wild which is
just insane when you think about the
history of this series so this formula
Nintendo's doubling down on it as it
seems like they should based on what the
community feedback is saying based on
what the sales based on what the reviews
are saying so if you're someone out
there like me it's like oh I really wish
they would add this it seems like they
found a formula that works now maybe
they'll still find a way to please some
of those fans as well who are hoping to
see traditional dungeons we'll just have
to wait and see and this is one where I
really want to hear from you guys are
you looking forward to tears of the
Kingdom what was your reaction to that
recent gameplay that they showed are you
more excited now less excited are you
still wanting to see more are you just
like all in you're buying it day one let
me know in the comments below me
personally I am still excited for the
game that may seem like a surprise given
all that I've said all that I'm kind of
concerned about going forward here but
by and large Nintendo just has such a
good track record and at the end of the
day that's what I keep coming back to
they have such a great track record I
don't think I don't think they would
release this game if it didn't have
enough to differentiate itself so I have
high hopes for that the technical side
of it I know I'm just gonna have to get
over that it's still going to be in my
mind for a while I'm gonna be thinking
man this would look so much better if
this was a switch 2 or a switch Pro but
like I said maybe I'll play it mostly on
handheld or I don't know just wait for
an emulator or something nah I'm
definitely not gonna do that I'm gonna
have to play it if you guys would like
to see my full reaction to that tears of
the Kingdom trailer though we actually
did a live stream right here on YouTube
I'll link it here on the right side of
your screen you can see my full reaction
there as always guys thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon